♪ ♪ ♪
- 18h à Istanbul: C'est l'heure
du bulletin de nouvelles
de "Halk TV", une télévision
privée suivie par des millions
de Turques. C'est aussi une
des rares télévisions encore
indépendantes du pouvoir
en Turquie. Mais sa jeune équipe
en paie parfois le prix.
- Comment la Turquie, candidate
à l'Union Européenne et membr
du G20 et de l'OTAN, en est
arrivé là aujourd'hui?
(manifestations)
Depuis 20 ans, elle est le pays
d'un seul homme: Recep
Erdogan. Démocrate, et
conservateur musulma il prend
le pouvoir en 2003 au sortir
d'une grave crise économique.
La Turquie devient alors
un modèle de développement avec
une croissance moyenne de 7% par
année.
ANNE ANDLAUER, autrice
- Les disons 10 premières années
de son pouvoir en tant que
premier ministre à la tête
de la Turquie sont des années
de prospérité croissante pour
l'économie de la Turquie au sens
large, mais pour les citoyens
turcs en particulier qui voient
leur pouvoir d'achat augenter
de façon exponentielle,
les investissements directs
étrangers affluer en Turquie.
- Anne Andlauer vient de publier
un livre sur Erdogan.
Correspondante radio à Istanbul
depuis 12 ans, elle nous parle
des ambitions de celui qui est
devenu, au fil des réformes,
un président tout puissant qui
a la main sur la Justice,lelelee
centrale.
- Recep Tayyp Erdogan n'a fait
que de la politique presque
toute sa vie et sans doute croit
en une mission quasi divine pour
son pays.
- Parmi ses réalisations,
la transformation complète du
réseau de la santé devenu très
efficace. Il a fait construire
des dizaines de grands hopitaux
comme celui-ci à Istanbul.
- Député pour l'AKP, le parti
fondé par Erdogan et
depuis 2002, Akif Cagatay Kilic
est un proche du Président.
- Une affirmation que de
nombreux Turcs n'aimeront peut-e
du pays.
- Ce qu'on a vu pendant
la période des années 2010 c'est
un Recanananananananan qui de
plus en plus se sent menacé,
avec plusieurs tournants.
c c c c c c c choses se gâtent
après une manifestation
écologique pour sauver le parc
Gezi d'Istanbul que
le gouvernement veut raser.
Le mouvement se transforme en
manifestations de colère contre
Erdogan et embrase tous les
pays. Des milliers de personnes
sont blessées par la police.
La liberté d'expression en prend
un coup.
IBRAHIM KABOGLU,
député opposition
- Plus il a cumulé les pouvoirs
é
le régime politique vers
l'autoritarisme.
- Ibrahim Kaboglu est député
pour le principal parti
d'opposition. Il se souvient,
de l'autre évéiiiiiiiii
a renforcé la méfiance du
Président Erdogan.
(explosions)
Dans la nuit du 15 juillet
2016, une faction de l'armée
turque tente un coup d'État,
l'État d'urgence est décrété.
Commence alors une purge sans
précédent: plus de 100 000
fonctionnaires sont congédiésnes
de personnes sont arrêtées.
- Les garanties
constitutionnelles concernant
ntntntntntntntntntnt être
bafouées quotidiennement
- Ce qui au départ était
présenté comme une action
pour débarrasser l'État
de ses putschistes s'élargit
très tôdedededededededededes
opposants.
Le Président affiche aussi plus
que jamais son islamisme
et des Mosquées apparaissent
un peu partout au pays. Quant
à l'économie turque, elle est
en proie à une inflation de 54%
et le pouvoir d'achat de la
population est en
Les prochaines élections sont
prévues en 2023, et verront
deux Turquies s'affronter.
Celle de Kas
où a grandi Erdogan. Il a
ses affiches partout, on a
l'impression d'y être déjà
en campagne électorale.rérérérér
le pays, il a créé des emplois,
je l'aime beaucoup. d d d d d de
la santé, de tous ces ponts
et ces routes qu'il a bâtis.
Il a fait entrer la Turquie dans
l'ère moderne.
- Mais il y aussi la Turquie
de tous ceux qui rêvent
d'un pays différent.
- La démocratie turque est-ce
que ça existe? Je ne sais pas,
on recule. Moi j'ai 78 ans,
j'ai vraiment vécu beaucoup
de choses en Turquie;ododododods
difficiles, mais jamais aussi
difficiles que maintenant.
Par c
le père d'Ege Ogunz lui avait
suggéré de ne pas nous parler.s,
7 millions de jeunes voteront
pour la première fois
en Turquie, soit environ 11%
de tous les électeurs.
- L'action d'aller dans une urne
et de porter un candidat
ou un parti est un peulqlqlqlqlr
rempart de la démocratie
en Turquie.
Irfan Degirmenci promet,
quoiqu'il arrive, de continuer
à faire son métier. Tout en
rêvant à plus de liberté pour